[Musica]
buonasera allora quanti hanno le
auricolari collegati con la partita
dell'italia
qualcuno ce o con l'app per le notifiche
perché un po mi sento un po in quel quel
pezzo di film della corazzata potiomkin
o di fantozzi però dalla parte sbagliata
allora i film come qualcosa di fantozzi
così come il teatro così come i fumetti
sono tutte le finzioni però sono dei
linguaggi che forse delle volte ci
raccontano delle verità meglio di tante
parole
e stasera parliamo di supereroi e
partiamo col primo supereroe
ho scelto superman supereroe per per
antonomasia superman è un po particolare
perché lo superava il contrario
tutti i supereroi nel nei fumetti sono
degli umani che si travestono da
supereroe mentre superman è un supereroe
che si traveste da umano per cui viene
da un altro pianeta krypton e il costume
un mantello è fatto con la coperta con
cui è venuto sul pianeta terra e super
mano ispira il tema del talento e la
prima considerazione che faccio è che
superman su krypton è un normodotato
normale come tutti gli altri sulla terra
invece a dei super poteri straordinari
allora il talento una questione di
contesto che ciascuno di noi ha del
talento sul quale ha dell'abilità che
gli vengono un po meglio degli altri ma
deve trovare se come deve avere il
coraggio di trovare il contesto dove
puoi esprimere questo potenziale e se
noi siamo dei leader
secondo me è un dovere trovare i
contesti dove i nostri follower
collaboratori possono dare il meglio
e finita l'epoca di vedere secondo me ad
esempio l'organizzazione come delle
fotografie dove tu c'hai la casellina
metti dentro la persona no le
organizzazioni sono come dei film no e
quindi vi lavora nel tempo e allora puoi
fare convergere quelli che sono
l'organizzazione con il talento dei tuoi
collaboratori delle persone che ti
seguono e piano piano far convergere
talento e posiziona cook che occuperanno
così le persone sparando loro potenziale
e trovare una organizzazione super
performante e poi un'altra cosa insegna
su promesso talento e che
la cosa particolare che è un po comune a
tutti i supereroi e perché quando hanno
acquisiscono i super poteri devono
imparare a usarli ma quando noi abbiamo
un talento secondo me è nostro dovere
soprattutto all'inizio investire tempo
ed energie per svilupparlo
non dobbiamo accontentarci che qualcosa
ci venga meglio degli altri dobbiamo
trasformarlo in eccellenza e per far
questo dobbiamo continuare imparare e
studiare e dall'altra parte allenarci
mettere in pratica anche sbagliando per
potenziare punto il nostro talento però
arriverà un certo punto in cui i
miglioramenti diventeranno sempre più
difficili e le energie per migliorare
sempre più più grandi e tra l'altro poi
a un certo punto con sé vicino
all'eccellenza
i miglioramenti li colgono soltanto
pochissime persone gli esperti no noi se
noi pensiamo se noi guardiamo uno sport
che non conosciamo
non riusciamo a capire la grandezza del
gesto tecnico ma è una volta è una notte
insonne per la televisione vedo il
curling
se avete presente carlo sport invernale
no vedevo queste bocce sul ghiaccio le
persone con la scoperta e mi veniva da
dire
questa roba qua possono andare anch'io
olimpiadi no perché perché non
conoscendo quello sport non riesco ad
apprezzare il gesto tecnico
allora quando noi cresciamo abbiamo
investito nella prima parte nostra vita
sul talento
gli dobbiamo avere la forza il coraggio
di investire il nostro non talento cioè
di investire quell'attività che proprio
non ci vengono perché perché lì è visto
che partiamo molto dal basso con poco
possiamo raggiungere dei buoni risultati
non diventeremo dei fenomeni di madina
buoni risultati e la nostra performance
complessiva sarà di grande migliorerà di
tantissimo questo superman poi è un
altro supereroe interessante intrigante
wonderware e la prima super eroina della
dc comics e del 1941 e quando nasce
questo super eroina perché prima sono
nati prima supereroi maschi non come
sempre quelli a quell'epoca non parte
benissimo no perché è una donna
guerriera perché parte con attributi
maschili e c'è stato tutto un periodo in
cui una donna per esprimersi dove in
qualche modo copiare gli uomini no
il peggior complimento che si poteva
fare quella donna halep darli delle
caratteristiche di genere maschile no
come se brava perché se come un maschio
invece juan dell'uomo si evolve man mano
nell epoca fino ai film di oggi e
rappresenta sempre un po come si è
sviluppata la leadership al femminile
molto interessante perché negli anni
settanta diventa un'icona femminista e
oggi nell'evoluzione che sta compiendo
abbiamo una supereroina indipendente che
non ha paura di stare da sola perché è
legata al passato ma non fa della
tradizione un modello assoluto per dire
no allora per essere realizzata devi
sposarti figlio maschio un figlio
femmina no e riconosce questa edizione
ma non diventano un vincolo per
l'autorizzazione e poi ha l'intelligenza
emotiva non nasconde le proprie emozioni
non ha paura di mostrarle
allora io quello che penso studiando la
leadership perché forse oggi è arrivato
il tempo in cui sono i maschi che devono
imparare un po la leadership delle donne
perché oggi per essere un ottimo leader
per la capacità di relazionarsi bene con
ciascuna dei tuoi collaboratori per cui
devi in qualche modo avere la capacità
di ascolto attivo di empatia e capacità
di entrare nei panni dei tuoi
collaboratori deve avere appunto
l'intelligenza emotiva per cui oggi si
sono ribaltate secondo un po le
situazioni sono i maschi devono imparare
dalle donne per come essere leader
e poi un supereroe che mi piace
tantissimo proprio che ma piace a tutti
evolver in wolverine è pazzesco perché
allo scheletro di adamantio alla
capacità di rigenerarsi l'ipo di
spuntano le lame dal dalle mani a me fa
un po sorridere perché la produzione
italiana dell'animale wolverine e il
ghiottone cattivi state attenti arriva
il ghiottone o ridere no perché non è
non a quella forza diciamo quell'impatto
volgarino il ghiottone però la ipo di
super potere che ha e quello che è
immortale che un superpotere che noi
umani invidiamo tantissimo evolvere
perché da sempre mi ha cercato di
diventare immortali akil egizi con le
piramidi della mummificazione anche
sempre alla ricerca della vita oltre la
vita
poi le tecniche le tecnologie
l'ecri o cose e non ci siamo riusciti e
anche qua c'è un po una differenza di
genere nel senso che le donne sono
avvantaggiate perché loro sono già un po
immortalino perché hanno il dono della
procreazione per cui proseguo la specie
noi a quel dono diamo un contributo
piccolino talvolta anche troppo rapido
qualcuno dice no nei maschi noi invece
vogliamo in qualche modo rimanere
lasciare una traccia no per cui scrivere
un libro avere una strada intitolata
un'epoca nuova per rimanere immortali
perché effettivamente se ci pensiamo
quand'è che uno rimane immortale quando
è quando viene ricordato da un regalo
più grande che possiamo fare le persone
care e quello di ricordarle divenne un
pezzettino nostro cuore modo dosi
rimango veramente immortali allora
bomberino immortale questo a questo per
poter immenso eppure è infelice come no
tutti vogliamo essere lui ce l'ha ed è
infelice perché per due motivi il primo
è perché le persone che tutte le persone
che conosce è invece sono mortali per
cui lui appena si affeziona la persona
saggia che l'adora perdere e questa una
tragedia che non sopporta che lo porterà
poi di fatto a non volersi più
affezionare nessuno
il secondo motivo è perché ha tutto il
tempo del mondo a disposizione
allora sei tutto il tempo del mondo
disposizione nulla diventa importante
perché puoi fare tutto quando quando
vorrai
e questo secondo me è un insegnamento
molto grande per noi perché noi che
siamo mortali
siamo fortunatamente mortali abbiamo una
scadenza anche se fortunatamente non
sappiamo quando sarà ci permette questo
tempo limitato di farci concentrare
sulle cose veramente importanti di non
cadere nella trappola di questa
modernità ci fosse calindri direbbe il
logorio della vita moderna
ne siamo molto reattivi arrivano ha
telefonato dobbiamo risolvere la
telefonata una mail quella mail col
sapone ma rispondere subito no siamo
molto motore attivi però è l'essere
troppo cattivi ci fa perdere forse di
vista loco scorso veramente le cose
importanti in oro dell'esempio sempre
quello che ti mando whatsapp ti scrive
che ho mandato una mail a no e tu ti
senti nobili dove sa che l'ho letto
no avete la mente su amici sito chiamami
e devi chiamarlo a roma perché ma perché
non posso più gestire il mio tempo no
e così cadiamo nella trappola in questa
guerra di trincea facciamo come criceti
corriamo corriamo alla fine stiamo fermi
ricordarci che non possiamo gestire il
tempo non perché tempo passa possiamo
solo fatto impiegarlo bene o male
evolvere mi ricordo tutte le volte che
tu hai impiegarlo bene per le cose
importanti
e poi ci sono i fantastici quattro
fantastici quattro sono il primo gruppo
della marvel non sono del 1100 61 fino
allora e gli eroi erano solitari erano
di superare solo di solitari e poi la dc
comics concorrente della marvel e fa la
justice league mette insieme di
supereroi i fumetti vendono tantissimo
la marvel dice anche noi dobbiamo fare i
nostri supereroi allora chiamano stanley
che più grande creatore di supereroi che
abbiamo avuto e stanley decide di fare i
fantastici 4 lui dice io voglio farli di
carne sangue voglio farli che sono molto
umani no perché questi supereroi erano
un po lontani dall umano e fantastici 4
qual è il trucco che usa l'ipa le gare
per cui c'è mister fantastico che si può
allungare che è ma che è sposo è sposato
con la donna invisibile
apro parentesi anche lì donna invisibile
perché è una caratteristica un po delle
donne l'invisibilità kg diventa un
superpotere poi l'add on è visibile e
sorella della torcia umana di quello che
si infiamma e poi c'è ben grimm la cosa
quello fatto di pietra che l'uomo
allungabile mister fantasy sono i
migliori amici
quindi queste legami affettivi portano
un sacco di discussioni però portano
anche il fatto una solidarietà è enorme
perché è veramente un po tutti per uno
per tutti perché si vogliono bene
quindi c'è un legame affettivo e
dall'altra parte c'è una diversità
assoluta sono molto diversi
e questa diversità di porta un sacco di
litigi perché per che gestirà diversità
in faticosissimo ma dall'altra parte una
ricchezza enorme ricchezza enorme perché
se io o persone uguali a me al limite
posso potenziare le mie capacità posso
fare di più ma se o persone diverse da
me possiamo fare tante cose che mai ci
mangi eravamo insieme e studiando i
fantastici 4 venuto in mente un
un episodio che mi è capitato qualche
anno fa quando si viaggiava era negli
stati uniti vado vado a visitare il
grand canyon e è un fenomeno rarissimo
la nebbia che non si vedeva niente mi
era capitato anche da ragazzo quando era
dato capo nord che c'era nebbia qualcuno
vuol venire vacanza con me ma questa è
un'altra storia un'altra storia insomma
non si vede niente andiamo tutti nel
negozio di souvenir lì ci sono i now
capo gli indiani nativi andiamo li
guardiamo le cose il negozio pieno entro
un signore arrabbiatissimo così
arrabbiato che parla ad alta voce dice
come è possibile è tutta la vita che
sogno di vedere il grand canyon
ho fatto un viaggio lunghissimo sono qua
da 6 ore e non lo sto vedendo noi ci
allontaniamo un po perché è un po
agitato un certo punto incrocia con lo
sguardo la commessa la guardia j tu
cos'hai da guardare non ha fatto niente
però in qualche modo doveva scaricare
star abbiano e sta commessa invece di
abbassare lo sguardo come avrei fatto io
che non sono un cuor di leone sostiene
lo sguardo di questo signore egli dice
guardia
posso capire che ogni tanto sul grand
canyon ci sia la nebbia ma quello che
non riesco a capire come si fanno a
dedicare solo 6 ore al sogno della
propria vita l'ostinarsi calma
esce non so se si butta dal grand canyon
e non l'ho seguito però questa roba qua
mi ha illuminato perché perché una
persona diversissima la teca non c'entra
niente con devo forse proprio perché non
c'entra niente con te ti può aprire uno
spiraglio che per te diventa un panorama
completamente nuovo e lì ho capito la
forza della diversità e anche la
difficoltà di accettare il punto di
vista diverso ecco questo quello che mi
ha insegnato i fantastici quattro e poi
arrivò all'ultimo supereroe che spider
man l'uomo ragno un uomo ragno è
favoloso e il primo supereroe
adolescente quindi che va a scuola e
tanto che è un po scanzonato me diverte
molto perché prende in giro i nemici
mentre li combatte
il dramma tirare delle volte è un'ottima
terapia per affrontare le cose
impegnative e spiderman però non diventa
super eroe quando 15 poteri quando lo
punge il ragno radioattivo no ha
soltanto di superpoteri non è ancora su
però diventa super eroe quando uno dei
due filosofi più importanti nel mondo
fantasy
uno è appunto lo zio ben di dell'uomo
ragno l'altro yoda di guerre stellari o
lo zio sembri dice grandi poteri
comportano grandi responsabilità in quel
momento lì e lui diventa supererebbe non
è una questione di avere potere o poteri
è una questione di perché gli usa e il
senso che dopo no e quindi infatti se ci
pensiamo
se ci pensiamo anche cattivi gli
antieroi hanno un sacco di poteri di
super poteri non sono differenti da quel
punto di vista solo che il supereroe
l'antieroe dicevamo cambi il perché
l'antieroe lo fa in maniera egoistica
usa li potrebbero poteri per dominare
per sconfitti per per fare male per
distruggere il pianeta mentre supereroe
lo fa per aiutare gli altri e per
salvare il pianeta
quindi quello che conta è il perché più
che più che il cosa è anche questo mi è
venuto in mente mentre suonavano i
ragazzi prima bravissimi che su nave
battiato specialmente che settimana
scorsa martedì vado in un negozio di
gli strumenti musicali vado lì entro e
vedo un signore un commesso che avrà
avuto più della metà non lo dico però
insomma molti chilometri sulle spalle
quindi avrà venduto
non so centinaia e migliaia di chitarre
e stava vendendo una chitarra un
ragazzino un piccolo ragazzo è quello
che mi ha colpito è che nonostante fosse
un lavoro che c'è se non so da vent'anni
sempre lo stesso lavoro sempre stessi
strumenti eccetera
o come toccava quello strumento come la
passione che ci metteva nel descriverlo
il l'entusiasmo quel luccichio che
vedevo negli occhi mi ha fatto capire
che questi non stava mettendo una
chitarra ma sta valutando quel ragazzo a
realizzare il sogno di diventare un
musicista allora ricordarci ogni tanto
il perché facciamo le cose forse la
lezione più importante i malati
supereroi e forse tutte le volte che noi
facciamo un gesto così con un perché
importante stiamo stiamo qualche modo
esercitando i nostri super poteri
probabilmente senza saperli di avere
grazie
[Musica]